- You have a thing in your household,
like cooking paella is like
a very dangerous thing.
What and why?
What?
- Yeah.
- What happened?
- I think this is fake news, people.
This is something that's going around.
(audience laughing)
- No, I hear it's about fire.
- Okay.
- All right.
I am a dad.
(audience laughing)
- Check.
- That I'm a cook.
That I believe my daughters
to be out of danger's way.
I will have them better prepared for life
if I teach them from early on
about the dangers of the world,
not putting them behind walls.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience chattering)
So yes, I let my daughters
use knives with barely,
they were two years old
and cook with open fire.
And sometimes the fires I make at home,
they can be very big cooking the paella.
(audience laughing)
And my...
And the fire is bigger than my daughters.
(audience laughing)
And the fire is a really big fire.
And when you have little
daughters and big fire,
and you're teaching your
daughter how to make the paella,
the fire sometimes is nice.
The fire wants to help
you, wants to kiss you
(audience laughing)
because fire is a good person
if you treat them with respect.
And I think the fire wanted
used to give kind of little kiss
to my daughter's eyebrows
(audience laughing)
and was a little, you
know, smelly little bit.
My daughters were overdoing it.
"Daddy, you burn me."
"I didn't burn you, it was the fire."
- It was the fire? (chuckles)
- I say, "Don't tell
anything to mommy, please.
No, just let's keep it."
I mean, yeah, or when I
forgot one of my daughters,
yeah, in the supermarket.
But I came back.
(all laughing)
Hey-
- But I came back.
- Hey, I didn't have salt
and was very important.
I was baking a fish in
salt and my daughter,
"Yeah, you got the salt,
but what about me?"
(all laughing)
So, yeah,
but between the fire and that,
I don't feel like even-
- Father of the Year. Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Yeah. Fire, yeah.
- Oh, my gosh, that looked cool too.
The thing you were cooking it in.
That was really cool.
We showed the video of that
big black thing, that was cool.
- A paella pan.
- That is, no.
(audience laughing)
But what's the thing underneath
of it? Was it connected?
- Yeah, it's like, I don't
know what it's called.
- Look, I'm gonna be real with you.
I make like nothing.
So, like, I'm not a cook.
So, I've never seen-
- No?
- Yeah, yeah. No.
- You're not a cook?
- No, and I am...
This is not fair 'cause-
- You don't sing when you cook?
- No. Yeah, that's...
I got the one talent, man.
Yeah, that's it.
(audience laughing)
It's the one.
- I don't think
she has one talent.
- It's the one.
- I think she has many, many talent.
(audience cheering)
- I can't even make eggs.
I can't even make eggs.
- All right.
People of America, the "Kelly
and Jose Cooking Show."
- Yeah.
- She teach me.
- I make my egg. (chuckles)
- She teaches me to sing
and I teach her to cook.
Bingo!
(audience cheering)
- As long as no one...
Okay, I'll do that.